so I've moved out of my flat now but
unfortunately I'm not allowed to move
into my new house yet so in the meantime
I'm staying here in bath with my mum yay
no today it's time for another challenge
charlie yeah it's that thing that I do
with the challenges and pain and the
suffering for me and the entertainment
for you why today's Challenger is
Charlie's aladár orsela dear as and
they've challenged me to remake one of
my old videos now the video that I've
decided to remake is one that you might
have seen actually it's a very old video
in which I electrocuted myself it's not
even a video that I put on YouTube
actually it's something that I made for
an event called stick aid which I'll
talk more about later boy you need to
know right now is two things firstly I'm
going to electrocute myself at this and
secondly don't try this at home now back
when I made the original video I use
this game called lightning reaction to
electrocute myself and that's what I
have this time I bought a new one this
one's called lightning reaction reloaded
with adjustable shock so hopefully this
will be more painful I start myself off
at full shock level with just one of
these thingies in my hands
ah oh my god
ah that is so much more painful than it
was before
ow in my hand ow Oh
so what I've learned is that full shock
level probably isn't the best place to
start so I brought it down to a number
two shock level which is the middle and
I'm going to use two electric devices
I'm genuinely afraid that I might like
pee my pants or something oh oh oh ah -
is much more manageable much more
manageable oh my god
the jump from two to four is just like
insane I'm gonna try a level three okay
so - perfectly fine no problem three
it's not that nice really but it's
manageable for horrible absolutely
horrible I did not enjoy that at all
so the obvious next step is to push it
up to number four and use two of them so
okay once again don't try this at home
please
okay
aha I don't want to do any more thing in
the interest of preserving my life I am
going to stop now oh I would need to
tell you about stick hey now uh the
original video that I made I made for
stick 8 which is this thing on my friend
Myles does every year he does this
24-hour live chat to try and raise money
for the charity UNICEF this year I'm
co-hosting with Myles for two of the 24
hours from 7 to 8 p.m. and from 12:00 in
the morning till 1:00 in the morning
that's British Standard Time they're
actually tickets to be in the studio
audience if you want to come so I'll put
links down there in the doobly-doo TM
wheezy waiter and the whole thing's
happening on the 1st of October which
also happens to be my 21st birthday baby
that's all um thank you for watching me
electrocute myself come to stick aid if
you want and happy birthday to me
for next week bye you've just had the
almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool it's the end screen it's the
end screen it's the end screen